hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
evaporation or lyophilization which is
best
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by labconco
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
kelly williams
director of laboratory equipment at
labconco corporation
and jenny sprung senior application
specialist
at labconco corporation kelly and jenny
you may now begin
your presentation
welcome to lapconco's webinar titled
evaporation or lyophilization which is
best
my name is kelly williams and i'm the
director of laboratory
products and i will be joined by jenny
sprung
senior application specialist thank you
for joining us today
during this presentation we will not be
able to answer this question
and tell you which process is best as
the answer to this question is based on
your individual samples and your desired
outcome however we will be discussing
each process
in depth so that you can determine the
best simple prep
method for your application we will also
discuss
critical points you should consider in
your equipment selection
for each process so that your results
can be optimized
as you can see from this agenda we will
discuss
lyophilization versus evaporation
but the theories of sublimation and
evaporation
how to choose equipment for sample prep
and your equipment options
the goal of both lyophilization and
evaporation
is to remove moisture from a sample
however each process
does it in a different way
lyophilization starts with the frozen
sample
where an evaporation the sample begins
as a liquid
a lye alphalyze product typically leaves
a dry cake or powder
where an evaporated product results in a
wet pellet
or thin film that is deposited on the
side of your sample tube
if your sample will be re-suspended
after your concentration process
freeze drying might be a better process
for you as lyophilized cake is
easily to dissolve usually easy to
dissolve
and produces a high percentage of
recovery
temperature differential is another area
to consider
what is the freezing point of your
sample for freeze drawing a temperature
a temperature differential between the
collector and your frozen sample is
required this can be a challenge if your
sample contains low freezing point
solvents
if your collector is minus 50 and your
sample's freezing point is minus 60
you will not be able to freeze that dry
that sample
without removing the low freezing point
solvents first
a temperature differential is not
required in an evaporator
thus evaporation is an easier simpler
process
that does not vary greatly from sample
to sample
because of this temperature differential
requirement
the best option to freeze dry low
freezing point samples
may be to use both methods evaporate the
solvent out of the sample first
and then freeze dry the sample finally a
deep vacuum is essential for
a freeze dryer but in evaporation a
higher vacuum level
is optimal
sample volume sizes the number of
samples and tube format
all need to be taken into consideration
when when deciding which method
is best for your sample both freeze
drying and evaporation can accommodate
from one to many samples in the same run
both process processes offer many
options and accessories
based on the sample size in the
containers your samples are
in a variety of rotor slats tube holders
and blocks are available
with both types of equipment however if
the samples are bulk or solid
a freeze dryer may be a better option
the time requirements can be
dramatically different with pre-shrine
requiring more time
if a fast process is desired then an
evaporator might be a better option
with each process having many options
the biggest determinant of the optimal
choice between the two methods
often is the temperature sensitivity of
your sample
generally freeze drawing is better for
temperature sensitive samples than
evaporation
first let's talk about freeze drying or
lyophilization
lyophilization is a greek derived word
meaning solvent lovely
loving like i stated earlier why
although ice material
is easily rehydrated making it a great
process for sample preparation
if you need to do a solvent exchange and
resuspend your sample
the biggest difference between freeze
drying and evaporation is the
preservation properties
that free shrine gives to samples in
sublimation
solvents pass directly from a solid to a
gas
and bypass the vapor stage the
sublimation process
preserves the samples properties even
during long-term storage at room
temperature
the rate of sublimation during freeze
drawing is controlled by the pressure
and temperatures that you are using
this graph provides a great visual on
the differences between these two
processes
the triple point is where the two curves
meet
evaporation occurs above the triple
point
and sublimation or lyophilization is
occurring below the triple point
with the x-ask x-axis being vacuum level
and the y-axis being temperature level
evaporation is occurring at higher
temperatures and higher vacuum levels
where sublimation is occurring at lower
temperatures
and lower vacuum levels when freeze
drying it is important to cool the
materials below its triple point
being below the triple point ensures the
sublimation is occurring rather than the
evaporation
this prevents your samples from melting
now we will discuss the theory or
the theory of idea of evaporation
evaporation is the simpler process for
the addition
where with the addition of heat the
liquid will simply change over
into the gas phase since this process is
happening at the surface the greater the
surface area
the faster the process
during both lyophilization and
evaporation
sample temperatures will decrease as the
liquid molecules change
phases this is referred to as
evaporative cooling
because of the evaporative cooling
effect greater amounts of heat can be
safely added to a heat-sensitive samples
at the beginning of the evaporation
process without damaging the sample
this is done to speed up the run and
reduce the time requirements
the evaporation process does not require
a vacuum
and can be done by simply heating or
boiling the sample
however in most cases vacuum is used to
lower the boiling point of the sample
this is to speed the process or
to protect heat sensitive samples by
having them boil at lower
temperatures now that we know more of
the details on these two methods
i'm going to hand it over to jenny to
discuss the specifics
regarding your samples
great thanks kelly now we're going to
talk about
the different types of evaporators for
your method
choosing the best equipment for your
sample prep step is
very important a few questions to keep
in mind
are is speed important are the samples
heat
sensitive or even free sensitive are the
solvents
volatile that you're planning on using
and what are the solvents
and what are the size of your sample
this could vary depending on
what type of equipment you choose to use
once you have answers to all of these
questions
you can decide the best equipment for
your needs
labconco offers a full line of
evaporators
we offer freeze dryers vacuum
concentrators
and nitrogen evaporators
to start we're going to cover the stripe
process the primary goal of freeze
drying is to protect the biological and
chemical structure of the sample
through sublimation the process
typically takes anywhere from 24 to 72
hours on average so as you can see
it is not a quick process
free shredders can be used for long-term
storage where samples are typically
stored under vacuum or
nitrogen they can also be used as a
sample prep step
when long-term storage isn't required
and the samples may be sensitive to heat
from a vacuum concentrator or a nitrogen
concentrator
a temperature differential is required
between 15 and 20 degrees
with the collector temperature being
colder than the sample's freezing point
the temperature differential between the
sample and the collector will establish
a vapor pressure differential
because of this vapor pressure
differential the moisture in the sample
will migrate to the condenser coils
the natural migration of the water
molecules to the condenser is called
cryo pumping one thing to keep in mind
if you do not have this temperature
differential your samples may melt
during the process
which could cause an undesirable outcome
choosing a freeze dryer based on the
sample eutectic temperature
or the freezing point is detrimental to
your process
if you're using a mixture of solvent the
lower temperature solvent needs to be
looked at for the correct freeze dryer
for example hclc samples that contain
acetonitrile water and tfa
would require a minus 84
freeze dryer because of the acetal
nitrile which freezes that minus 42
degrees
the same model will also be able to
liapilize aqueous aqueous-based samples
as well as those solvent-based samples
there are three important steps to the
lyophilization process
pre-phrasing primary drying and
secondary drying
if one step is done incorrectly
lyophilization
may not be achieved and your outcome
might not be what you want
the freezer you choose has to be colder
than your sample eutectic
temperature if you're freezing low
freezing point solvents in a minus 20
degrees freezer
they may not freeze to a solid but
become more of a slush
this is not optimal for the freeze dry
process
and may cause issues with your freeze
dryer as well as your vacuum pump
you can also control the rate of your
pre-freeze
slower pre-freezing will result in
larger crystals which will freeze dry
faster
it's best to know your samples and how
they respond to the freezing process
before you begin fast pre-phrasing
creates small ice crystals
controlled cooling or annealing creates
large ice crystals which are then easier
to freeze dry
so again knowing the best pre-phrasing
step for your method and for your
specific sample
is important
there are three ways to pre-freeze your
samples stub
slant or shell freezing slant and shell
freezing
will give the most surface area which is
optimal for the freeze dry process
controlled heat supplies to the sample
during primary dry
drying is what drives the freeze drive
process and encourages the removal of
water vapor from the frozen product
temperature controlled shelves supply
precise amounts of heat to the sample
remember colder is not always better
as heat transfer is important for this
freeze dry process to work
a vacuum pump that can achieve a level
of 0.002 millibars is required
a vacuum pump is going to encourage the
free flow of water molecules
from the product by evacuating the
environment around the product
and it removes the non-condensable acids
next we'll talk about secondary drying
secondary drying
is when you're adding additional heat to
the sample to drive
off the residual seven to eight percent
of moisture
this is best done on a tray dryer with
controlled heat
some advantage of the freeze dry process
is that the applications are
limitless ranging anywhere from
pharmaceutical
to zoos to universities and even
high-end restaurants
the process is good as a sample prep
step as well as long-term storage
a wide range of sample sizes can be done
in the right pre-dryer
[Music]
disadvantages however is that freeze
drying is not a quick process
due to the sublimation process if you're
looking for a quick sample prep
step an evaporator might better be a
better fit for you
for the freeze dryer we have many
choices available
and you also have choices of drying
chambers including manifolds
with ports as well as tray dryers a tray
dryer can be used for bulk samples
microplates or test tubes and racks
where port types are good when samples
will need to be added throughout the
process
or just a few samples will be run at one
time
we'll now talk about vacuum
concentrators
vacuum concentrators are great for small
samples that can withstand
some heat a vacuum concentrator will use
heat and vacuum
to evaporate samples leaving a wet
pellet at the end
not a dry cake like the freeze dry
process
sample sizes typically range from
microliters
to about 25 milliliters and even more
depending on the rotor that you choose
although vacuum concentrators use
centrifugal force
they will not take the place of a
centrifuge which spins at higher rates
preheating the chamber is recommended
prior to pulling a vacuum to get the
unit ready for samples
rather than a 100 dry cake like freeze
drying
the end result of a vacuum concentrator
is a wet pellet
at the bottom of the tube
evaporation can be a relatively quick
process
depending on the sample and the heat
input and it also covers a wide range of
samples from aqueous to alcohol
because a temperature differential is
not required for the vacuum
concentrator process
if samples are heat sensitive a
refrigerated
back is an option the less heat transfer
the longer the process will take but you
will be assured that the samples will be
safe
the labconco refrigerator center vap
cools from -4 and will heat up to
positive 100 for the
process
many options are available for a
concentrator including an optional cold
trap
for samples larger than five milliliters
a cold trap
is recommended a strobe light allows you
to see the samples during the run
without shutting the system down to
check them
an oil-free diaphragm pump is typically
used and many times venting into a
chemical fume hood
is recommended
and now kelly will cover nitrogen
evaporators
thank you jenny i'm going to talk about
our vortex or nitrogen evaporators
both of these types of evaporators they
use heat
in either nitrogen blow down or vacuum
to evaporate
samples quickly
[Music]
they both use a vortex evaporation
this motion increase the surface area of
the sample
resulting in faster evaporation like i
said below
earlier in the webinar the more the
surface area the faster the evaporation
or sublimation
evaporation rates are about 10 times
faster
in a vortex vacuum concentrator than
they are
in a centrifugal concentrator and the
main
reason for this is the sample is in
direct contact
with the heat source and you can see
from from the photo
um that the vortex does
move the sample so it does go up the
side walls
of the the tubes this vortex motion
is an orbital motion that constantly
washes down the side walls of the
glassware
resulting in a high analyte recovery
endpoint determination is available on
some of these units
in the endpoint can be chosen between
3ml
or less
typical vortex evaporators use
nitrogen but there is also a vacuum
model
version in this in this model
if solvent recovery is required a vacuum
system
with the coal trap is the only option
let's go over some of the advantages
that the vortex and the nitrogen
evaporators have
like i mentioned it's tens times faster
than a vacuum concentrator
um solvent exchange is easy in a vortex
evaporator
because the constant wash down at the
side walls during the process
so you're going to get higher recovery
the nitrogen blowdown
evaporators accommodate a large number
of samples in the same run
and can can accommodate sample volumes
from less than one amount to 450 ml
and like i mentioned earlier endpoint
determination
is available on some of those models
the main about advantage of the vortex
evaporators is the speed of evaporation
with the wide range of sample sizes they
can be used in applications
that range from combinatory chemistry
environmental
to drugs of abuse if dryness is an
optimum for your samples endpoint
glassware is available
some of the disadvantages of why you
would not choose a nitrogen
or vortex evaporator is heat is required
for optimal
evaporation um so you're if your sample
is heat sensitive
you're going to be a little um you're
going to want to go a little slower and
not put as much heat in
many of these types of nitrogen
evaporators
use a water bath that can cause
cross-contamination and rusting of
components i'm happy to say that the lab
conco versions do not they use a dry
block
and um another
item is because the you can consume a
lot of nitrogen
so much that we don't um when we
recommend a nitrogen
evaporator we do not recommend them with
nitrogen tape
thanks you will need a nitrogen
generator
if samples are heat sensitive a vortex
nitrogen blow down
evaporator is not the best option you're
going to want to use the vacuum model
because the vacuum lowers the boiling
point of that sample
depending on the model you choose a
vacuum nitrogen or vacuum
pump or nitrogen generator are required
so both of these types of evaporators
are going to need either nitrogen or a
vacuum pump
they both um come with a
have available multiple blocks that are
available
and even custom blocks can be made for
unique glassware
a coal trap and secondary trap are used
only with the vacuum system
and you really don't have to have that
unless you're worried about
solvent recoveries and are trying to
minimize the solvents going out
through your fume hood
thank you for joining us today i hope
you have a better understanding
of what is involved in
freeze drying and what is involved in
evaporation and some of the choices that
you have to make
so depending on your sample and what
your outcomes are
you now have the information to make the
best choice for your lab
i want to also share with you um
or ask you to keep in mind lab conco for
many of your other laboratory needs
we are here and we're ready to help you
choose the best model for your samples
at this time jenny and i will be
answering any questions that you may
have so thank you so thank you for
actively actively joining us today and
if you have any questions
um please send them in we would love to
hear from you
you kelly and jenny for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is
why is it not recommended to fill
vessels more than 50
full for freeze drying will this damage
my samples or will it just take longer
to dry
that's a great question we typically
will recommend not filling more than 50
full for a couple of reasons first
reason would be you want more
surface area in your flasks so by
filling them less than 50 percent full
and putting them on a slant or a shell
freeze
you're going to freeze dry a lot quicker
you're also going to reduce
the risk of breaking your glass or due
to expansion of the pre-freeze
so great question we get that one a lot
all right thank you and we have another
question
my freeze drying runs last for several
days how can i speed up my
hope is process on mute still um i
i'd be happy to take that one um
the freeze drawing and evaporation both
of the time required
is a direct input of heat and the heat
transfer so evaporation
and freeze drying um the more heat and
the more efficiently you get that heat
into a sample
the the quicker it's going to go any
freeze drawing it's tricky
in that you have to monitor or regulate
your heat
because you don't want so much heat that
your sample starts to melt you always
want to stay below that triple or you
take
eutectic point so
the heat and surface area will also
determine time
so if you want to reduce your run times
and freeze drying
you you can do two things simply
increase your surface area
which will will help and the other thing
would be to put the heat in
we always recom put more heat in we
always recommend the customers to start
on the conservative
side and and start freeze drying
successfully and getting the results
they want and then they can um
adjust their heat to put more heat
and to get it done in a faster way again
you're not going to want to put
so much heat in that your samples start
melting back
but that that is how you would speed it
up increase the surface area
and add more heat to the sample
all right thank you kelly um i have
another question
i i am needing to get water out of my
somewhat heat sensitive sample
which is the best method for me
well we have two options for heat
sensitive samples one would be the
freeze dryer
and what you have to keep in mind with
freeze drying is you do need to know if
your samples are also
freeze sensitive so cold sensitive
if they are then you'll want to look at
the what we call the refrigerated
center of app and that's basically a
vacuum concentrator that can cool from
-4
but it'll also heat to positive 100
degrees
so those are both two good options for
heat-sensitive samples
but you'll need to know your process
you'll need to know your sample
and what it can withstand and then what
your end point wants
needs would be whether if you want a
fully dry sample or if a wet pellet is
fine
oh great thank you jenny and we have
another question coming in
which method would you recommend to
preserve a recombinant antibody
we are having problems with storage at
minus 20 degrees c
in liquid phase
i definitely think um that is
i would if i were you i would definitely
try to freeze dry it before you
uh put it in the in the freezer um
freeze drying
between the two methods freeze drying
definitely has
the best preservation of activity
it is is the more gentler is more gentle
on the samples
so if if that were my situation i would
definitely try freeze drying at first
and then storing it even um though
people um
freeze dry a lot of our customers freeze
dry
many of them will still store their
their samples in the freezer so there's
nothing wrong
with freeze drying at first and then
putting it in the sample but
i'm pretty confident you're going to
have a lot better success
with your your antibody so thanks for
asking
all right great thank you kelly and we
have another question
i am looking to replace my lab's very
old freeze dryer
there are many different choices and
temperatures and sizes to choose from
how do i decide which one to get
i think what we need to look at with
something like this
is is the fact that older freeze dryers
use
different type of refrigeration
so what may have worked in an older
freeze dryer such as some solvents
working in a minus 55 or minus 60
it may not be true today so you really
need to look at two things
the sample that you're using and the
combined
freezing point of that sample whether it
be solvents or aqueous
and then the second thing is how much
sample you want to remove at one time
so those are the two most important
questions when we're trying to spec out
a new freeze dryer and what's going to
work
best so yeah that would definitely be
what i would what i would look at first
once you decide then
give us a call and we're happy to walk
you through and give you some
recommendations for the best unit for
your needs
great thank you jenny we have another
question here
i had samples for dry and i used both
freeze dryer and
a vacuum concentrator when i used the
freeze dryer we had a dissolving problem
when we used the vacuum concentrator it
wasn't properly dry what should i do
yes that is a good question and it
sounds like
um you have a sample that is more
difficult
uh to freeze dry and evaporate
um from what it sounds like if you um
we can reach out by email and we will
get the specifics of what your sample
you have in your sample but what you're
describing of the hard to dissolve
problem
is it's your sample is probably
undergoing what we call melt back
and what will happen is samples will
start melting back
and then they will form clumps instead
of forming
um cakes that are very easy to
re-suspend
they form clumps and they um are harder
to dissolve
and some of the ways you can prevent the
clumps are
making sure that your sample is not
going to melt back
and like we discussed in the
presentation having that temperature
differential
is critical so if your sample does
have some solvents in it or even some
salts
that make um that really suppress that
freezing point
in your collector's only a minus 50 you
probably could run into some trouble
like this
so we're gonna we can give you more um
ideas
individually of what to do but what um
some of the more common advice that we
give
would be if it does contain a solvent to
get that solvent
out of that sample first if you can do
some nitrogen blow down or some simple
vacuum concentration to get the solvent
out then go ahead and freeze it and
freeze dry it
but what you're describing sounds like
some melt back
so i noted your email
and we will be reaching out to you by
email
all right thank you and it looks like
that's all we have time for today
thank you kelly and jenny do you have
any final comments
for our audience today
yes i just want to thank everybody for
joining us
we hope with this information we've
shared you can now determine which
sample prep method
is best for you or perhaps how you can
perfect the the method that you're
already using
if you have additional questions in the
future do not hesitate to contact us
at www.labconco.com
we have application specialists
available
by phone chat and email who are happy to
help you
i see that some additional questions are
coming in so
don't worry we will reach out to you
individually
and and help you with those but just
want to want you to know that we are
always here
and ready to help so um and we do help a
lot of people so we have some really
good ideas
so don't um don't hesitate to contact us
all right well thank you both kelly and
jenny for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor labconco
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye